congressman ralph norman who's a member
of the house homeland security committee
had a chance to question the secretary
this week congressman good morning to
you
two days of questioning he sat through
them you listened to it and participated
as well what are your top takeaways
carly secretary mayorkas is a congenital
liar who has total contempt for the
constitution total contempt for the rule
of law and total contempt for the
american people
how he can appear and lie like he's
doing is amazing to me you know if we're
controlling
the
southwest border what's how do you
define uncontrol
you know he's a he's a
unelected bureaucrat who's doing
tremendous harm to this country it's
actually going to be hard to turn around
and he also blamed trump for it take a
listen
we inherited a broken and dismantled
system that is already under strain it
is not built to manage the current
levels and types of migratory flows only
congress can fix this
is there any any evidence congressman
norman that this is trump's fault
you know it's this follows a pattern to
this administration uh under the last 12
months of the trump administration 513
000 were apprehended under the last 14
months of the bi-administration
1.2.3 million four times five times as
much it's total uh he's lying and he has
no
uh he has no he
has such disregard for the truth facts
don't lie uh but he can't explain it and
i guess the easiest thing for him to do
is con continue to blame
the previous administration it's very
simple build the wall
and that's something that he is
not going to do and actively fighting
against so it's now in
the texas national guard's hands to try
and build border fencing and i believe
that some of that
is getting done right now what do you
think the end goal is for democrats i
mean we're talking a possibility of 18
000 illegal immigrants trying to get
into the country each day which would
completely overwhelm border patrol why
is this happening what's the end goal
here
the end goal is for them to retain power
the end goal is for them to get
the registration for all the illegals
and
hope and pray that they vote for the
democrats but you know it's it's again
it's total disregard and you know you're
looking at such numbers as we've never
seen
uh you know this is a travesty for the
for the country and uh you know once
they're in this country how do you get
them out and you don't but the end game
for the democrats is to control power
and we're going to continue to highlight
it and make him come before the cameras
and try to explain it but it's just more
lies yeah all right congressman ralph
norman it does appear to be political
thank you for joining us this morning we
appreciate it
my pleasure all right hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now